being on time being punctual was laid at
the feet of some oppressive super
structure it's utterly imbecilic that's
trait conscientiousness by the way to be
punctual part of orderliness and
dutifulness there's no evidence
whatsoever that that varies by ethnicity
or race or Supremacy there is evidence
that if you are like that you are more
likely to succeed it's the most potent
personality predictor of success in
algorithmic domains managerial and
administrative domains so hard work
works and in fact the degree to which
hard works is actually one metric of the
health of a society the higher the
correlation between conscientiousness
and outcome the healthier the society
you want a bulk of the credit to go to
the people who are the most productive
it's because if you want them to keep
making stuff you have to do that what
you don't want food you don't want
shelter why would you not reward the
people who provide it differentially
even your own narrow self-interest would
require that